موسكو. والصين تنقل جيشها
للاراضي الروسية فكيف سيكون وضع
بالانضمام الى حوار وطني قادم
يهدف لحل الازمة بعد مقاطعته او
من يمثله للاجتماع. اما في سوريا
فقد دفع الجيش التركي خلال ساعات
اهلنا في الجزائر اجعلها بردا
وسلاما عليهم. اتهم الرئيس
وصفها باسطورة السلاح الغربي.
نشر الجيش الاوكراني مشاهد مصورة
الاستخبارات الغربية بتزويد كييف
بالاحداثيات لتنفيذ ضربات
في مقتل ثمانية وثلاثين شخصا
واصابة العشرات في اربع عشرة
منازلهم بسبب النيران في منطقة
سوق هراس الحدودي. قلوبنا مع
المدعومين من ايران؟ لكن ماذا عن
جزيرتي ابو موسى وطنب الكبرى
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي بسرقة
السعودي اعلنت القوات الموالية
للامارات السيطرة الكاملة على
الليل بثلاثة ارتال الى الداخل
السوري. الارتال دخلت الى مناطق
اليمني مع غياب الطرف اليمني
تماما ولكن ما علاقة الاماراتيين
جوازات سفره خلال تفتيش عقاره في
الاسبوع الماضي. امريكا بدأت
بارسال صواريخها الفرد صوتية
لاوكرانيا بينما ينتظرون ردة فعل
مؤتمر القوى السياسية العراقية
ان المجتمعين اتفقوا على تشكيل
وطنب الصغرى الاماراتية اخذتها
منكم ايران لتبحثوا عنها في
جرابلس وعفرين واعزاز الحدودية
بريف حلب. تسببت حرائق الجزائر
من الشهر الحالي بعد تسع سنوات
من ارسال باريس قوات الى الدولة
ولاية شمالي البلاد. كما فرت
ثلاثمائة وخمسون عائلة من
تظهر تدمير الية عسكرية روسية في
نوفا كاخوفكا بمنطقة خرسون
الاوكرانية جراء استهداف من قبل
الخاصة. كشفت مصادر خاصة من داخل
يجتمعون مع وفد فرنسي لمناقشة
اعادة تصدير الغاز من بلحاف
لي وفقا لبيان صادر عن الجيش
الفرنسي يوم الاثنين الخامس عشر
اليمن؟ الاحداث والتطورات. غادرت
اخر وحدة عسكرية فرنسية اراضي ما
شويجو ان العملية العسكرية
لبلاده في اوكرانيا بددت ما
والعسكرية؟ الم تدخل الامارات
اليمن من اجل محاربة الحوثيين
محافظة شبوة اليمنية. وفي ظل
الحرب الروسية الاوكرانية. وبعد
وفد يضم قيادات سياسية لزيارة
مقتدى الصدر في النجف لاقناعه
الواقعة في غرب افريقيا. اتهم
وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شويجو
لانشاء قاعدة اسرائيلية في جزيرة
ميول اليمنية التي تمتاز بموقعها
الفرنسي والمقرب من الحكومة
الفرنسية. وبعد ان قصفت باكثر من
عسكرية. وفي كلمة امام مؤتمر
موسكو العاشر للامن الدولي اعتبر
ستستمر الامارات في بسط نفوذها
على مفاصل اليمن الاقتصادية
طائراتها التجسسية فوق الاراضي
الروسية واضاف ان القوات الجوية
بهذا الاتفاق وكأن شبوة محافظة
اماراتية وليست يمنية فالى متى
التي يخوضها الجيش الاوكراني وقد
حذر كذلك بريطانيا من اطلاق
الاستراتيجي المطل على مضيق باب
المندب وذلك حسب مقال نشره موقع
خمسين غارة مواقع تابعة للحكومة
اليمنية المدعومة من التحالف
روسيا? العبث اماراتي يستمر. بعد
ان طبعت واعطت اسرائيل فرصتها
الروسية واجبرتها على الخروج.
فماذا يريد البريطانيون من
ان فرض بوتين حصاره على اوروبا
ها هم اليوم مندوبون اماراتيون
عن اعتراض مقاتلة روسية لطائرة
استطلاع بريطانية عبرت الحدود
الروسية تلقت اوامر لمنع اي تسلل
واصفة الامر بانه استفزاز متعمد
فائقة اسرع من الصوت وقد وصلت
بالفعل الى اوكرانيا لاستهداف
يتحمل مسئوليته الجانب
البريطاني. وكانت موسكو قد اعلنت
العام للامم المتحدة انطونيو
جوتيريش وماذا عن بوتين?
وتحديد الاهداف بدقة ويستطيع
توصيل المعدات والادوات العسكرية
الحدود السورية. واشارت القوات
السورية الى ان تلك العمليات
اراض اخرى وهي الان تطفو على
امواج المحيط الهادئ. فهل يكون
على قصف القوات التركية. فماذا
سيحدث غدا برأيكم? لننتقل الى
ويجب ان يستريحوا. ليدخل رجال
بوتين اليون المعركة. وهنا يدخل
انظمة الرادار الروسية ليرد
بوتين ويصرح ان واشنطن تصب الزيت
اردوجان والذي اعلن عن وصوله
لاوكرانيا لينشئ قمة ثلاثية مع
الكلب الروبوتي الروسي نينجا وهو
في الطريق لارض المعركة حيث
بريطانيا تزعج روسيا. بوتين يقول
يكفي هدرا للجنود والقوى البشرية
وزارة الدفاع الامريكية عن ارسال
صواريخ مضادة للردارات بقدرات
بات اكثر عدوانية من خلال اشرافه
على ادارة العمليات العسكرية
مقتل سبعة جنود اتراك في ثلاث
عمليات متفرقة ضد الجيش على
على النار. وان الولايات المتحدة
تتحمل مسؤولية اطالة امد الحرب
يطبع مع اسرائيل ويرسل لها سفيرا
ويدعي انه لن يترك فلسطين وها
الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي بالاضافة
الى الطرف الثالث وهو الامين
سيدافع عنها. والجانب الاخر
يتجاهل القصف الاسرائيلي ليرد
فلسطين الجريحة. واضافت شاووش
اوغلو في مؤتمر صحفي عقده مع
بدوره شدد وزير الدفاع الروسي
سيرجي شويغو على ان حلف النيتو
غنائم بالاوكرانية وتعلن عن ضم
اربع مناطق من اوكرانيا لاراضيها
في اوكرانيا. هنا روسيا تستعرض
سلاح الغرب الذي حصلت عليه من
وهي
قرارا بتعيين سفير لها في تل
ابيب يا خسارة الوقت الذي اضعناه
عسكرية سورية بمحيط عين العرب.
وهنا تعلن القوات السورية عن
نظيره القرغيزي في انقرة ان
تركيا في الدفاع عن فلسطين
مقتل وجرح نحو عشرين شخصا في
غارات تركية استهدفت قاعدة
تأتي ردا على قصف الجيش التركي.
هنا نقطة حياد. فالجانب الاول
يمتاز بمواصفات خارقة. فهو قادر
على اطلاق النيران بقاذفة صواريخ
والقدس وغزة. ها انت متأكد من
ذلك يا لتعلن بعدها سوريا عن
وزير الخارجية التركي مولود
شاووش اوغلو ان بلاده اتخذت
هذا سبب تجمع كل هذه القوى في
روسيا اليوم? تركيا واسرائيل قال
الايام القادمة لاعلان تحديها
للزعيم الكوري. وبعد سيول، كذلك
بالمحيطين الهادئ والهندي وسترسل
القوات الجوية الالمانية طائرات
ناهيك عن المراقبة وتميزه
بالرؤية الليلية. لتعلن بعدها
القوات الصينية والهندية
والبيلاروسية يا ترى هل هي فعلا
مناورات سلمية ام ان لها اهدافا
اخرى ليأتي الرد من بوتين? الغرب
يسعى لتشكيل ناتو اسيوي جديد في
المحيط الهادئ. الغرب يتوجه نحو
ذاهبون الى مناورة وصفت
بالتاريخية حسب تصريحهم حيث ستمر
عسكرية الى واستراليا وكوريا
الجنوبية. وبمناسبة ذكر كوريا
العسكرية لتكون اشبه بدرس نعده
لكم في الايام القادمة. وهنا سرب
من القوات الجوية الالمانية الى
سنغافورة وهي الاقرب الى تايوان
بمتابعة مسلسل ارطغرل وما اقبح
المصالح السياسية لكن لا هو يا
منطقة منزوعة السلاح وهي التي
ستزورها نانسي بيلوسي خلال
الجنوبية المجنون يرد اليوم على
الباسوس نانسي بيلوسي وذلك
بنزع سلاح بيونج يانج سمعوا
اصوات صواريخ كروز تحلق فوقهم
الامنة وهي التي تقع بين
الجارتين. لنعد لابن الكريملين.
باطلاق صاروخين اثنين من نوع
كروز باتجاه المنطقة الامنة اول
محارق الفحم لتربوا عطشكم من
الطاقة? لا يا عزيزي. انهم
والذي لم تشغله حرب روسيا
واوكرانيا ليعلن عن استقبال
والصين. فماذا تريدون يا ابناء
انجلا ميركل? لماذا لا تعود الى
عندها عرفوا اجابة الزعيم الكوري
الذي مرت صواريخه على المنطقة
الروسي. الصين تقولها شاهدوا
ماذا سيحدث في هذه المناورة
العم سام مفادها لقد نصحناكم
بالا تلعبوا بالنار وانتم
مشتركة ضخمة مع الجيش الروسي من
حيث المساحة وعدد القوات
المشاركة وستجري في ثلاثة عشر
ميدانا عسكريا في اقصى الشرق
تجاهلتم. اليوم جنودنا سيذهبون
الى روسيا. نعم فقد اعلنت وزارة
الانتقام. اعلان عسكري صيني هو
بمثابة ارسال رسالة غامضة لابناء
ينهي الحرب والجزائر تصحو على
كارثة. بينما العراق يصل لحل
الدفاع الصينية انها سترسل قوات
عسكرية الى روسيا مناورات عسكرية
نهائي والامارات تقصف اليمن من
جديد. فما هو السبب. حفلة
يرد على الباسوس ردا عسكريا.
اردوغان في اوكرانيا بعرض مغر قد
ولهذا السبب الطائرات البريطانية
تخترق الاجواء الروسية والمجنون
الهدف وسرب من القوات الجوية
الالمانية يمر تجاه تايوان.
هكذا قالت الولايات المتحدة
الامريكية فماذا تقصد امريكا وما
هي هذه الخطوة؟ وكيف سترد موسكو؟
بينما رجال بوتين الاليون يدخلون
نحن نعلم ان هذه الخطوة ستزعج
روسيا ولكن كان لابد من اتخاذها.
خط المعركة والرئيس الصيني يرسل
قوة عسكرية ضخمة لروسيا، فما
العالم في الايام قادمة برأيكم.